[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue en point de vue
ravi de vous retrouver pour notre rendez
vous quotidiens et comme chaque jour
nous allons traiter quatre sujets on va
tout de suite découvrir en images
ensemble le gouvernement veut remettre à
plat la fonction publique supprimer 50
mille postes d'ici la fin du quinquennat
et si on en profitait pour supprimer le
statut de la fonction publique eh ben on
en parlera on parlera aussi de cette
petite phrase de benjamin griveaux le
porte parole du gouvernement qui
considère que laurent wauquiez c'est le
candidat des gars qui fument des clopes
et qui roulent au diesel
peut-être at-il perdu une bonne occasion
de se taire on en parlera et vous lui
donnerez votre point de vue nous
traiterons aussi du sujet des petites
maternités et plus particulièrement de
la maternité du blanc c'est dans l'indre
qui va fermer malgré les protestations
des habitants est ce une bonne mesure ou
non on vous écoutera là dessus et puis
on parlera de l'europe et des nuages qui
n'en finissent pas de de se multiplier
sur l'europe de monsieur macron c'est sa
meilleure alliée angela merkel qui a
annoncé qu'elle ne se représenterait pas
en 2021 qu'elle va quitter la présidence
de son parti
bref est ce la fin de l'europe de macron
ce sera le quatrième thème que nous
aborderons aujourd'hui avec nos invités
bonsoir à chevigny vous êtes journaliste
à causeur votre mensuel publie ce
mois-ci en couverture un sujet sur la
censure illustré par notre confrère eric
zemmour bonsoir laurent papilles vous
êtes analyste économique pour l'iref
l'irem c'est un think tank dont on peut
dire qu'il est de tendance libérale un
assez clairement une libérale même si
ici ça n'est pas un gros mot
olivier ravanello bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste co fondateur et président du
média en ligne explicite point info et
vous avez été l'un des patrons de la
rédaction d'i télé
entre autres choses nicolas vidal est là
aussi bon soir vous êtes journaliste
rédacteur en chef de putsch putsch
c'est à la fois un site internet et un
mensuel en vrai papier votre créneau
c'est le débat d'idées et la culture
beaucoup de cultures ils ont exactement
c'est la culture qui fait débat la
culture qui fait débat c'est un joli
slogan on commence donc au jour de cette
émission avec notre premier sujet
dimanche dernier gérald darmanin a mis
le feu à la prairie en expliquant que ce
serait peut-être pas mal dû recruter des
fonctionnaires qui n'est pas le statut
de fonctionnaire si vous avez oublié
cette intervention
réécoutons là ensemble c'était sur
europe 1 nous aurons la possibilité de
garder un statut c'est important de
garder pour une partie sans doute de la
fonction publique notamment les
fonctions des plus régaliennes et puis
nous avons la généralisation du contrat
aujourd'hui et n'est pas possible par
exemple pour un employeur territoriales
pour un maire d'embauché sur des postes
à responsabilités des gens sous contrat
alors que demain la loi permettra de le
faire nous alors ça c'était la première
étape de l'offensive gouvernementale qui
était évidemment concertée et puisque le
lendemain c'est à dire hier le premier
ministre a réuni le gouvernement est
responsable de patrons l'administration
centrale pour leur expliquer qu'il
fallait changer les choses en profondeur
et notamment supprimer des postes alors
arraché le business est ce que c'est une
bonne idée de supprimer le statut de la
fonction publique c'est-à-dire
d'embaucher des fonctionnaires comme on
embaucherait des salariés du privé
non parce qu'il faut bien comprendre que
ce statut il n'est pas anodin il a un
sens il garantit certaines choses il
garantit une certaine neutralité
il garantit une certaine forme de
sécurité pas seulement une sécurité pour
le fonctionnaire lui même mais dans sa
dans son action dans son rôle dans sa
profession même et qu'à force comme ça
un petit peu on peut se demander aussi à
qui acquittent acquise a profité pour
quoi que je suis pas sûr que les
français dans leur ensemble soit pour
une baisse du nombre parce que c'est ça
aussi un derrière un cache cache
il ya 5000 ans et demi mais il faut les
différencier parce que très souvent les
gouvernements ont l'habitude de mettre
la focale sur un type de fonctionnaires
qui attise peut-être parfois un petit
peu les passions et les critiques c'est
à dire les fonctionnaires des
collectivités territoriales mais y'a pas
que il ya aussi ceux de la fonction
publique hospitalière
il ya ceux de la fonction publique
d'état donc qui rassemble la justice
l'éducation nationale et tout ça ce sont
des gens qui ont un rôle extrêmement
important à jouer et et notamment pour
les français moyen les français
des territoires qui ont besoin d'avoir
un service public extrêmement fort alors
aujourd'hui fragilisé ce statut baisser
le nombre parce que parce qu'en fait
c'est je crois 50000 d'ici 2022
c'est quelque part fragilisé un petit
peu bon nombre de français notamment une
certaine classe moyenne parce qu'on sait
on ne pourra pas couper seulement dans
la fonction publique territoriale il
faudra également couper dans l'éducation
nationale dans la justice dans l'armée
etc
alors je rappelle les aubes les chiffres
à qui étaient dans le programme
présidentiel d'emmanuel macron il y
avait 120 mille suppressions de postes
en tout pour la durée du quinquennat
dont 50 milles dans la fonction publique
d'état
les autres postes seront donc supprimés
dans les deux autres fonctions publiques
que vous avez fort bien énuméré la
fonction publique territoriale les
collectivités locales
et puis les hôpitaux alors on vous
demande votre avis un bien sûr sur
twitter et alors c'est formidable parce
que c'est très partagés donc le débat
aura d'autant plus d'intérêt
selon vous faut-il supprimer le statut
de fonctionnaire vous ne répondez oui à
48% et non à 50 2%
avec cette précision donnée par jean la
suppression oui sauf pour les domaines
régaliens police armée justice
laurent papy quel est votre point de vue
sur ce sujet je sais pas si le projet de
réforme de l'état on a une fois de plus
aucune réforme de l'état c'est une
réforme qui est paramétrique derrière le
la notion statut de fonctionnaire vous
l'avez dit ça va être une une diminution
du nombre de fonctionnaires mais on ne
réfléchit pas vraiment à quel est le
rôle des fonctionnaires est ce que les
fonctionnaires doivent avoir un rôle
dans l'état enfin la taille de l'état le
périmètre de thaï ha c'est vraiment une
réforme qui est paramétrique maintenant
ce qu'on peut faire c'est regarder ce
qu'ont fait les autres pays
les autres pays européens les pays
nordiques qui avaient des masses de
fonctionnaires extrêmement importante
aussi et qui ont fait des grosses
réformes notamment sur le statut mais
aussi surtout sur l'ouverture à la
concurrence et ça c'est je pense le
éléments essentiels qui manque dans la
réforme de dans la réforme de l'état qui
aujourd'hui vraiment quelque chose de
paramétrique fin le le statut du
fonctionnaire s'est pas à mon avis
qu'ils principal le principal c est ce
que la mission de l'état c'est la
mission de l'état avait parlé la
fonction publique hospitalière elle
s'est dégradée en
j'ai pas envie de taper sur les
fonctionnaires y en a plein qui font un
très bon travail maintenant ils n'ont
pas forcément les bonnes incitations les
bonnes structures ya pas la concurrence
pour les aider à pour pour pour pour
donner les bonnes incitations 20 en
parlera sûrement sur la question de la
maternité le l'enjeu aujourd'hui il
n'est pas du tout touché par le
gouvernement olivier ravanello peut-être
que ces agents pourrait faire le même
travail sans avoir forcément ce statut
avec l'emploi vise la protection dans un
pays vous connaissez bien l'italie je
crois que le statut de la fonction
publique a été supprimé or l
administration tourner quand même en
italie
je ne suis pas sûr que ça soit forcément
le pays je pense pas en revanche c'est
un pays où il ya des collectivités
territoriales qui sont très fortes qui
sont plus fortes que chez nous des
régions qui ont plus de pouvoir et qui
font appel en effet à des des agents
locaux
j'y vois deux obstacles j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration mois pour un mot un terme
qui est public servante qu'on entend
chez les britanniques et qui dégage
tellement plus de respect
tellement plus un sens de la mission de
l'état que chez nous c'est un objectif
que j'aimerais bien qu'on finisse par
atteindre avoir un statut ça permet
aussi d'avoir des gens qui sont formés
de manière uniforme qui vont être
déployés sur le territoire et faire une
carrière sur le territoire et qui vont
bouger d'un territoire à l'autre
si vous avez progressivement la capacité
de recruter localement
vous risquez d'avoir par exemple des
régions qui seront plus riches qui
seront capables de faire des contrats
plus attractif de drainer vers eux des
gens qui ont peut-être plus d'expérience
et puis d'avoir des régions qui sont un
petit peu plus un peu plus fragiles
financièrement et qui ne pourront pas à
tirer vous avez utilisé le mot de
concurrence pour moi c'est un c'est un
danger qu'on refasse rentrée la fonction
publique dans une logique de concurrence
c'est la garantie que tous les français
ne se sentent pas traités de la même
manière et l'un des ressorts par exemple
du front national c'est justement dans
les territoires qui se sentent oubliés
et on voit très bien qu'il ya une qui a
un parallélisme entre la baisse du
nombre par exemple de bureaux de poste
ou d'intervention de l'état et de la
montée du front national parce que les
gens se sentent abandonnés par l'état et
que la fonction publique une des
premières missions qu'elle devrait re
remplir et mieux remplies c'est
justement d'être plus au contact de ces
gens et de leur dire bah c'est pas parce
que vous êtes dans une petite commune
dans un territoire qui peuplaient qu'on
vous envoie pas de fonctionnaire quand
vous avez des fonctionnaires qui sont
moins bien formés ou simplement qu'on
fait appel à des gens à des gens locaux
et nuit dernière chose je veux c'est la
porte ouverte au favoritisme au copinage
au contrat que vous allez donner à
quelqu'un qui a pas forcément des
compétences mais qui aussi peut vous
aider pour d'autres juste réagir
là-dessus pour moi la concurrence n'est
pas baisser la qualité du service et
baisser les moyens des services publics
ouvrir la concurrence et permettre à des
gens de venir proposer des services pour
un meilleur prix et pour une meilleure
qualité et donc le l'enjeu dans les
dents les communes n'ont pas voir vos
caricatures et encore une fois mais le
l'enjeu c'est pouvoir en suède on a des
gens qui sont capables de qui peuvent
proposer des nouveaux services de santé
qui peuvent proposer des choses qui sont
moins mieux mieux qu'ils sont qui sont
meilleure qualité et moins chères que
celles habitant la france est ce que la
vie est oui alors moi je suis assez
d'accord avec confrère olivier ravanello
ira chez ubi nas effectivement pour mon
scoop d'une tradition française
si cette espèce de démantèlement du
fonctionnariat ça peut aussi la perte
d'autorité du fonctionnaire également si
on m'en donnait à des contrats c'est
compliqué de savoir comment de quelques
comment va se va se va faire le
fonctionnaire et puis et puis après il
ya des gars des mots qui sont quand même
extrêmement
embêtant je lis de la part du
gouvernement pdv plan de départs
volontaires
je lis manager joli contrat je lis
efficacité c'est des mots et vous l'avez
dit reviens ravanello qui me pose
problème pour la fonction publique c'est
à dire qu'on libéralise quelque peu
amoindri de plus en plus ce que va être
le statut de fonctionnaire et ça pose de
véritables problèmes de fond à mon sens
alors comme vous êtes trois contre un
moi je vais donner mon avis et je suis
vendu plutôt d'accord avec laurent
papilles pour tout vous dire
et voilà voilà voilà argumentation c'est
que je comprends très bien qu'ils
fassent protéger les fonctionnaires des
démissions de l'état qui demande une
vraie indépendance donc les juges les
policiers
les inspecteurs des impôts parce qu'il
faut quand même pas qu'on puisse se
servir à la tête du client
mais regardez même l'armée missions
régaliennes ci s'il en est ce sont des
contrats
donc c'est pas parce que vous avez un
contrat que vous pouvez pas faire votre
métier correctement
et puis le dernier argument parce que ça
je vous laisse réagir c'est que en quoi
at on besoin d'être fonctionnaires pour
pour entretenir un lycée ce qui est le
cas de départ agent potentiel des
effectifs de la région ile de france ça
pourrait très bien de fait par des gens
du privé dira quand même plus de
souplesse eu plus de mobilité
pardon de mettre les pieds dans le plat
mais un peu moins d'absentéisme aussi
voilà mes arguments que je suis pas je
suis pas hostile enfin je suis parent
que bouté sur un statut qu'on ouvre ce
statut qu'on ouvre de nouvelles missions
d'accord mais je pense quand même qu'il
faut avoir un minimum de services qui
soient garanties de manière uniforme sur
l'ensemble du territoire
et encore une fois je pense que si vous
avez des régions qui sont plus riches
que d'autres
elles vont être capables de proposer à
leurs concitoyens à leur administrer des
services de meilleure qualité parce
qu'elles auront plus de ressources
autour d'elle vous pensez que si demain
vous voulez justement monter une
entreprise privée qui propose des
services aux collectivités territoriales
vous n'avez pas plutôt allé
dans aller taper à la porte de la région
ile-de-france avait pas plutôt allé
taper à la porte de la région rhône
alpes qui sont des régions riches plutôt
que sur des régions qui sont un petit
peu plus délaissées je pose la question
non moi je pense je vais vous dire toute
façon ces emplois il existe aujourd'hui
donc a priori ça coûterait pas plus cher
d'avoir des gens du privé est ce que
vous savez combien coûte un
fonctionnaire tout compris c'est à dire
le son sens sa période d'activité plus
sa retraite plus la pension de réversion
entre 2 et 3 millions d'euros alors
c'est normal il crée beaucoup de
richesses ou s'il participe à la vie
collective mais je veux dire c'est c'est
quand même très très très rigide
peut-être que cet argent pourra être
utilisé différemment mais ça n'est qu'un
point de vue que le fonctionnaire soit
d'un point de vue économique
un acteur comme un autre ça j'y suis
favorable
les statuts particuliers enfin
d'aujourd'hui de mon point de vue non
plus n'ont plus aucun sens mais que la
mission d'état soit différenciée d'une
mission qui peut être prise en charge
par le privé je pense que ça reste
important
la question du statut cache des
situations qui sont vraiment très
différentes il ya des statuts où on sait
que tout que c'est scandaleux enfin le
statut du fonctionnaire de l'assemblée
nationale on l'a révélé à l'iref c'est
un énorme scandale il ya des statuts qui
sont très précaires enfin il ya des
fonctionnaires dans la fonction publique
hospitalière qui sont c'est une
catastrophe le délabrement de leurs
conditions et donc la question n'est pas
vraiment le statut en soit la question
c'est quel est le rôle de l'état sur ses
missions
est-ce que l'on restreint où est-ce
qu'on élargisse qu'on permet à la
concurrence et des gens proposer mieux
pour moins cher c'est ça l'enjeu et ses
réformes là qu'ils ont été menés dans
les systèmes où il ya les meilleurs
systèmes de santé du monde mais on est
très mal classé le le mythe selon
laquelle la france a le meilleur système
de santé du monde il n'existe plus
aujourd'hui
les si on regarde le classement européen
on a sorti ça à l'iref le danemark la
suède la suisse sont loin devant et
proposera d'agents publics qui est
supérieur au nôtre alors vous le savez
c'est à dire que grosso modo les pays
scandinaves également le cas d'un canada
par rapport au nombre d'habitants on
nombre plus important et le royaume uni
est juste en dessous de nous donc qui
soit peut-être mal administré ou
certainement monsieur alors sur
administrer le système de santé anglais
encore plus fonctionnarisé encore plus
public que qu'en france les médecins
sont fonctionnaires en angleterre c'est
une catastrophe de le système de santé
anglais et j'étais catastrophe
alors dans cette émission les invités
sont beaucoup plus pertinent que
l'animateur est en fait c'est vous qui
avez raison le sujet qu'on voulait
traiter un peu plus tard c'est à dire le
sujet de la laddh cette maternité qui
est en train de fermer
tout ça c'est scellier en fait c'est la
présence de l'administration dans l'est
dans les territoires en particulier en
particulier ruraux donc j'interviewe la
régir en direct est ce qu'on peut
intervertir l'ordre de nos sujets et
parler tout de suite de ces petites
maternités qui fermait on me répond tout
de suite voyez c'est une grande maison
mais qu'il ya au live donc enfin ça à ce
sujet la police ce matin est intervenue
pour évacuer la maternité du blanc le
blanc c'est une petite commune 1 6500
habitants c'est dans l'indre et les
habitants de cette commune s'étaient
mobilisés pour que cette maternité ne
ferme pas c'est ce qui va être le cas
pourtant et du coup les femmes enceintes
pourront accoucher que à 52 km en allant
à châtellerault ouvert à 60 km en allant
à châteauroux tout ça est évidemment un
problème
écoutez ce qu'en pense jean luc
mélenchon le président de la france
insoumise
il a réagi justement sur cette fermeture
pour toute cette zone est bien il faut
aller à 60 km pour atteindre une
maternité 60 km bon je rappelle que la
circulation est limitée à 80 heures
maintenant
bah c'est une c'est une heure quoi à peu
près 1
parce que c'est pas comme ça comme une
flèche donc c'est une heure alors les
gens disent mes 2
j'ai perdu les eaux et après vous monter
dans une voiture pour faire une heure de
route
vous avez la probabilité de que le gamin
né de la nourriture et commence à être
un peu élevée pour finir donc les gens
ont peur dont raison voilà je suis passé
à chaque fois mais là les arguments de
jean luc mélenchon on l'a vraiment
absolument imparable
mais comme la situation est peut-être un
petit peu plus compliqué que ce qu'il
décrit
voici maintenant la parole donnée à la
défense et à dire agnès buzyn la
ministre de la santé il ya quelques
jours sur france info elle parlait de ce
sujet et elle disait en gros et ben oui
on doit fermer cette maternité parce
qu'on n'a pas le choix et voici pourquoi
problème que nous avons c'est un
problème national nous manquons
d'obstétriciens avait beaucoup de
maternité aujourd'hui ne sont pas
capables de remplir leur liste de garde
donc il ya des journées entières ou des
nuits entières dans lequel si les femmes
bien accoucher il n'y a pas d'autre
issue pour faire une césarienne en
urgence
j'ai demandé un audit sur cette
maternité qui étaient dans ce cas là
tous les médecins partent à la retraite
il n'y avait plus d'obstacle ricin et
l'audit qui nous a été donné montrent en
fait de très mauvaises pratiques dans
cette maternité avec une méconnaissance
des procédures d'urgence tant au delà
même de la liste des gardes qui n'est
pas rempli c'est une maternité
dangereuse nicolas vidal en fait ils ont
tous les deux raison quoi sauf qu'on se
dit a priori c'est ici un risque de
danger pour les fans la femme qui
accouche alors il faut la fermer cette
maintenant c'est compliqué parce que
pour avoir lu pas mal de choses ce sujet
ces dernières heures
il ya pas mal de gens aussi qui sont
pour la couverture cette maternité qui
sont qui sont pas d'accord avec agnès
buzyn et disent que c'est de la libye
concrètement moi la question je pose
aujourd'hui et je suis aussi un peu
d'accord ils ont une notion
effectivement sur ce kilométrage et on
pourra parler le prix des carburants
également parce que personne ne cherche
à 60 kilomètres ça peut faire très cher
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est ce
que la maternité la question et je la
pose simplement est-ce que la maternité
doit être doit être indexée sur un seuil
de rentabilité
aujourd'hui et est ce que pour moi pour
répondre à cette question c est vous
l'avez dit ces sujets secours bord c'est
un peu aussi le mépris de cette france
périphérique
voilà c'est un mépris la caméra prend de
faire échec à cette menace est ce qu'on
doit faire rentrer la logique marchande
dans justement au sein du service public
et aux simples mais il n'y a pas de
médecin il ya plus de pression que ce
que vous voulez la difficulté
la difficulté je vais je vais être
courte vous inquiétez pas mais je vois
que la famille allait demander la
difficulté en effet c'est celle en fait
des risques et du danger que ça présente
et ils sont doubles c'est un petit peu
compliqué c'est à dire qu'à à la fois la
distance parce qu'on sait que lorsque la
distance est supérieur à 45 minutes
ça pose des problèmes de sérieux
problèmes de danger et de risques à la
fois pour la mère et pour l'enfant mais
il ya également
il ya également le statut de ces
maternités qui font lorsqu'elles font
par exemple moins de 300 accouchements
par an c'est souvent le critère qui est
retenu ne sont pas présents des risques
ne sont pas assez habitués ne rencontre
pas ces deux cas d'urgence et il ya de
plus en plus de maternité qui sont
aujourd'hui d'obstétriciens attaqué
parce que parce qu'il ya des accidents
des accidents médicaux
donc c'est un rapport de la cour des
comptes je crois de 2015 évoqué sa non
pas sous l'angle marchand qui s'y plaît
à certains mais sur le plan sanitaire
sur le plan des risques en expliquant
qu' on ne pouvait pas fermer les yeux là
dessus donc ça c'est un point important
et il me semble un petit peu dangereux
de le balayer en expliquant que
il faut garantir coûte que coûte et
maintenir ses maternités et dans les
espaces ruraux
parce que sinon on se couperait de voilà
de toute une partie du service public
réponse nuancée j'observe c'est avec un
peu d froid pour tout vous dire c'est à
dire que là on est vraiment face à
l'administration de la santé l'économie
dirigée de la santé d'un côté on a des
gens qui nous disent bon ben là on a un
service de piètre qualité on va perdre
les maternités et puis de l'autre on à
la ministre qui qui qui en charge du
numerus clausus qui vous dit y'a pas
assez d'obstétriciens donc c'est elle
qui limite l'offre de deux médecins et
puis on à mélenchon qui 5 qui
s'improvisent obstétricien qui nous dit
oui ça c'est sais c'est pas normal on
aujourd'hui le lait les besoins de santé
ça ne peut pas être géré de manière
centralisée par l'état c'est pas quelque
chose qui est possible on arriva donc
des choses effroyables coupe 10 secondes
jour pas sa parole parce que aulas
justement pose la question sur sur
twitter faire sauter le numerus clausus
pourrait-il régler ce problème je pense
que oui c'est l'ouverture à la
concurrence le numerus clausus est une
barrière à la concurrence est limitée
elle vante d'être un grand nombre de
techniciens en fait c'est tellement un
brin d'herbe le chemin qu'ils sont qui
sont effectués c'est à bessens vous
pouvez mettre autant d'obstétriciens que
vous voulez dans la maternité il y aura
pas forcément vous êtes donc il ya un
débat pour savoir est ce que il ya
suffisamment ou pas de médecin est ce
qu'il ya suffisamment bas d'accouchement
ce n'est pas un ministère à paris qui a
des centaines de kilomètres qui va
décider de ça c'est quelque chose qui a
géré de manière locale
il faut décentraliser la question de la
santé l'ouvrir à la concurrence je
laisse gérer sa part des mutuelles
laisser gérer sa part des associations
si vous voulez papier de profits parce
que le profil vous fait vous fait hurler
mais non je suis désolé
justement la hurler le conflit ces
indicateurs que vous rendez service est
belle certes indicateurs là enfin vous
pouvez laborde et si vous voulez on peut
tout voir à travers ce filtre mais là il
n'est pas extrêmement pertinent parce
que le pr la première chose à savoir
c'est comment planifier face à des
problèmes
non c'est pas cette dichotomie elle
marche pas forcément c'est pas forcément
justement de le profil a mais c'est
aussi d'abord la question de la santé et
du danger que vous le vouliez ou pas il
me paraît quand même premiers sur cette
question c'est parce que c'est essentiel
qu'il faut surtout pas le laisser à la
bureaucratie enfin là on est on est face
à des gens qui nous disent cette
maternité offre des services de piètre
qualité
laissons les gens faire mieux fin c'est
ça qui est ok et chance d'urgence lé là
on vous pose la question sociale 8h01
vous l'avez vu sur votre écran les
petites maternités du pays ferment leurs
portes les unes après les autres faute
il empêcher ces fermetures et vous êtes
un peu plus des trois quarts à
considérer que oui il faut empêcher ces
fermetures olivier ravanello et ceci est
votre point de vue oui aussi et je
trouve l'argument du service qui n'est
pas optimale comme pouvant justifier la
fermeture là aussi un argument où on
prend les choses un peu à l'envers c'est
à dire qu'à tout prendre en prennent
obstétricien qui qui n'a pas rencontré
beaucoup de cas compliqués dans l'année
et le mari qui est sa femme à accoucher
dans la voiture je préfère encore un
obstétricien même s'il n'a pas vu
beaucoup de cas compliqués et au final
tout ça renvoie toujours à la question
de l'aménagement du territoire qui est
quelque chose qui a été complètement
laissés de côté on est face à une
situation économique qui nécessiterait
qu'on donne la possibilité à des gens de
pouvoir s'installer pouvoir plus vivre
dans des communes moins importante ou le
où le prix du logement est moins
important pour justement pouvoir amortir
des revenus qui sont en train de baisser
c'est une façon aussi de lutter contre
la paupérisation des classes moyennes de
permettre de pouvoir vivre à châteauroux
ailleurs dans de bonnes conditions et
pour vivre dans de bonnes conditions il
faut qu'ils aient des infrastructures
étatiques autour qui fonctionne il faut
qu'il ya un hôpital il faut qu'on puisse
se dire bah tiens je vais voir des
enfants dans cette région et ça va pas
être un problème
sinon vous allez avoir des grands pôles
régionaux qui vont devenir un peu
surdimensionné avec autour des grands
déserts à la fois médicaux mais pas
seulement
et des grands déserts ruraux donc je
pense que ça fait partie des dépenses
qui ne peuvent pas justement être
rationnel la fonction publique doit à
certains moments être rentable et à
d'autres moments ne pas l'être et qu'on
ait une vision d'ensemble où tout
s'harmonise oui mais il y a déjà des
fonctions publiques qui par définition
est par nature sont déficitaires et il
faut l'assumer il faut les regarder pour
le regardant nos voisins qui on va faire
des systèmes de santé qui sont bien plus
performant que système de santé français
qui ont ouvert à la concurrence avait
pas dire qu'on fait n'importe quoi ça
veut dire qu'il ya des mécanismes qui
permettent de fournir des meilleurs
services parce qu'il ya des gens qui
peuvent proposer mieux si demain il ya
un entrepreneur qui veut créer une
clinique ou créer une maternité
eh bien il va être en concurrence
déloyale face à la face à le système
administré de santé c est donc il va
pouvoir proposer des nouveaux services
aux habitants de châteauroux voilà c'est
ça le problème le problème et il va
avoir du mal à recruter parce qu'il ya
un numerus clausus qui empêche le nombre
de médecins ça vous a pas échappé que
vous allez dans une clinique c'est au
prix d un peu plus cher ça c'est faux
une corps une fois c'est faux c'est à
dire que il faut pas croire que c'est
gratuit on paye avec nos impôts
donc le système de santé n'est pas
gratuite ou c'est quelque chose que de
demander si c'est pas la même chose que
de se poser ses tanks ou loyer de chars
gloria ou de payer lui directement ou de
proposer à la collectivité
je ne suis pas exactement et donc de
raideur et qu'il existait maintenant je
le redis serait bien jeudi de permettre
aux mutuelles de concurrence et de
sécurité sociale mais aussi de réduction
des coûts là derrière effectivement avec
ce déséquilibre territorial où l'on se
retrouve avec des herbes et nico qui
vont qui vont devenir de plus en plus
arides et ça pose un vrai souci pour nos
concitoyens les plus volumineux les
territoires des grandes villes
des métropoles et des centres médicaux
performant et ça c'est un vrai problème
de fond favorable quand même que la
france est le pays je crois du monde
aujourd'hui à part peut-être la corée du
nord où la dépense publique est la plus
élevée donc on peut pas dire que on
manque de oui mais elle n'est pas
proportionnée aux enjeux se poser
régulièrement la question de sks que
cette activité ce secteur nécessite une
intervention publique ou pas et pour le
cas de la santé je pense que oui je
voudrais les points de vue a qui sont
parvenus sur lefigaro.fr et puis sur
twitter wang ward qui nous dit maintenir
un service pour un accouchement par jour
ça en fait des fonctionnaires de santé
payé à peu faire
christian qui nous dit il faut supprimer
toutes ces maternités et les hôpitaux
non rentables et alors christian l'unil
et sur la ligne il est sur la ligne de
l'iref
on veut des économies on veut des
économies ou pas si j'étais on finance
goethe à gré au sabre dans la dépense
publique c'est peut-être la vie de ses
provisions c'est une vision un peu
caricatural c'est à dire que moi je ne
suis pas pour qu'on coupe les les
finances et je suis pas pour qu'on coupe
les budgets l'important c'est d'ouvrir
la concurrence encore une fois c'est ça
qui permettra d'offrir c'est comme le
loto du patrimoine vous faire l'auto
d'inventer avec un appel alors je dis
rien je retire ce que j'ai dit sur
l'iref
et puis les intérêts des internautes des
internautes sur le chat du figaro live
qui le disent il faut faire sauter les
numerus clausus et éviter que ce soient
des médecins étrangers qui viennent
compléter compléter ce manque il ya un
un mot qu'on n'a pas encore employé sur
ce dans ce débat c'est le mot de
démographie parce que la réalité aussi
c'est que il ya de moins en moins de
naissances en france et donc en
particulier dans ces régions peut-être
qu'on a moins besoin de maternité à
cause de ça si je peux te faire une
comparaison faisant une comparaison avec
le logement je suis incapable de dire
combien il faut de mètres carrés de
nouveaux logements à château et
n'importe quel ministre n'importe quel
énarques ne sera pas c'est des
promoteurs qui vont venir et qu'ils vont
dire on a un qui ont observé une demande
et qui parce qu'il ya cette demande vont
pouvoir peut-être faire une rentabilité
et qui vont se dire là on va construire
des nouveaux logements la logement
saintrick vital c'est comme la santé et
on peut faire la même chose pour la
santé châteauroux
on rappellera que c'est la préfecture de
l'indre que désormais tous nos
internautes savent
et bien justement cesser ces zones qui
ont peut être besoin d'être davantage et
ds que le gouvernement les aime
il ya une déclaration de benjamin
griveaux le porte parole du gouvernement
alors c'est une déclaration of elle a
été reproduit dans le jdd le journal du
dimanche mais le ministre n'a pas
démonté donc a priori il a bien prononcé
cette phrase
il parlait de laurent wauquiez le patron
des républicains en disant ceci l'a
invoqué c'est le candidat des gars qui
fument des clopes et qui roulent au
diesel
ce n'est pas la france du xxième siècle
que nous voulons alors est-ce qu'il ya
ce que les communistes appellerait une
forme de mépris de classe chez benjamin
griveaux en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que laurent wauquiez a pas raté
l'occasion de donner une bonne claque en
retour au gouvernement
regardez c'était sur bfm tv
cette phrase du porte parole elle résume
tout leur arrogance tout leur mépris et
sans doute aussi leur incompréhension de
ce qui se passe en ce moment en france
le problème de l'essence et du gasoil
est en train de devenir un problème
majeur
en grèce ils ont exactement le même
problème est qu'un porte parole puisse
balayer ça d'un revers de main en disant
c'est que les boues ceux qui fument des
clopes et prennent leur voiture
c'est tout le résumé de ce qu'est ce
gouvernement en décalage total avec la
vie des français alors si vous voulez on
va on va scinder ce débat en deux
parties on parlera près de la hausse des
carburants donc du cap le le fond au
concret du sujet mais sur cette idée est
ce qu'il ya une forme de mépris pour une
france qui seraient passés du xxème
siècle dans ce gouvernement rachel green
as oui tout à fait j'étais très surprise
également être pas dire choqué de la
déclaration de monsieur griveaux à
croire que lui fait ses courses tous les
dimanches à naturalia et circulent en
trottinette magasin d'épicerie bio
je crois que c'est je crois qu'en fait
c'est bon c'est l'affrontement entre
deux politiques qui peut paraître
peut-être anecdotique mais en fait il
est révélateur d'un clivage qui s'est
créée qui s'est installée dont on a
parlé au moment de la présidentielle
notamment que christophe billy
voilà mis en lumière il ya déjà un
certain nombre d'années au final j'ai
omar qui a théorisé la france est
exactement
et je pense également à des gens comme
gérald andrieu qui a écrit le peuple de
la frontière qui sont penchés également
dessus c'est à dire une espèce de dédain
culturel entre de france qui
s'affrontent un clivage de classe qui a
changé un petit petit s'est déplacée qui
est maintenant devenu géographique et
sociale bien sûr toujours entre ce qu'on
a appelé les gagnants de la
mondialisation des grandes métropoles
et puis la périphérie les banlieues qui
auront joué entendre dans les années 70
80 90 même début 2000 le jeu de la
mondialisation mais qui en sont sortis
aujourd'hui perdant donc ce n'est voilà
ce petit accrochage si je puis dire
politique entre les deux hommes met en
lumière tout simplement un clivage qu'on
a vu pendant la présidentielle entre
macron et notamment marine le pen
nicolas vidal est ce que vous vous
sentez solidaire des gars qui fument des
clopes et qui roulent au diesel
moi quand j'ai entendu ça j'étais
surpris je trouve que c'était
consternant et j'ai vu le beauf de cabu
voilà ce personnage disney par cabu du
beauf avec la cigarette effectivement je
trouvais ça mais pour être plus sérieux
là dessus oui pour moi c'est la réponse
de premier de cordée aux autres voilà
cette france
benjamin griveaux notant le porte parole
du gouvernement
mais quel mépris de classe et là j'y
reviens de dire ça à son passé c'est
quand même assez incroyable et ayant ni
reviens parce que c'est un peu le fil
rouge ça c'est vraiment pour moi ce
dédain de la france périphérique de gens
hors sol et avec cette grille de lecture
et je suis d'accord avec vous rachète
bien là dessus il ya toujours ce paradis
tu m'as fait entre c'est ce combat plus
large européen national et européen
entre ces progressistes ouvert sur le
monde mobile flexible et puis le
nationaliste de populisme dénoncé par
emmanuel macron effectivement et après
il ya tout un champ sémantique qui va de
droite à gauche et il ya cette espèce de
mépris et on est toujours dans cette
vision un carnet de ce populisme et de
ceux de son progressisme absolument
absolument édifiant voilà même sur des
questions nationales et qui fait kiffer
consternant quand vous vous interrogez
sur twitter un condamné vous les propos
du porte parole du gouvernement benjamin
griveaux c'est plutôt oui c'est même
assez clairement oui mais à 61 % donc ce
n'est pas non plus un raz-de-marée ya
peut-être des gens qui considèrent
qu'après tout c'est ça vaut mieux que de
la langue de bois clos nous dit oui
ras-le-bol de son attitude et de ses
paroles insolente et inutiles et
christian qui nous dit moi je fume je
bois je suis au diesel on ne sait pas le
diesel qui boit c'est plutôt ce qu'il
veut dans sa voiture et il est choqué
par ce mépris de griveaux olivier
ravanello votre point de vue je crois
que c'est surtout un mépris de wauquiez
c'est pas mal fixé un esprit de wauquiez
et quand il dit ça c'est une formule
c'est pour ces poussées pour ces pour
attac évoquée je crois en plus qu'on a
tort de commenter des paroles qui ne
sont pas publics et d'en faire des
paroles publiques
ça a été tout
tout ce qu'on a vu dans le livre qui
était paru sur hollande exacte non celui
de travailler ma part de dire si pour ce
moment où on était dans l'est on était
dans les dans l'intimité d'une personne
qui peut se laisser aller à des mots
n'ont pas d'esprit mais au contraire de
faciliter simplement pour faire rire
l'entourage et je revendique le droit à
la blague de vestiaire entre amis mais
ça n'est pas une parole publique ce
n'est pas parce que vous êtes un homme
public vous n'avez plus le droit
justement à ce cercle là et d'en faire
un thème politique un thème de débat
public de demander de se positionner
je trouve que ce que ça n'est pas
honnête surtout quand on voit le passé
de grimaud qui a été un élu local qui a
souvent défendu des positions et une
écoute plus importante des territoires
et de lui faire ce procès là aujourd'hui
on peut lui faire d'autre il ya d'autres
il ya d'autres symptômes de ce2 ce2
cette incarnation du progressisme que
vous dénoncez etc mais pas sur ce coup
là je n'en ai pas oui on a quand même
d'être irréprochable enfin c'est quand
même un van du gouvernement et ça
traduit comme une mentalité un peu de
lait consiste vous voulez qu'on cite
tout ce qu'on s'est dit dans les
couloirs on est trente ans on n'a pas le
pouvoir et je suis désolé je suis à mon
entourage ils ne peuvent pas ils peuvent
passer à travers quatre heures chances
de podium c'est de l'intimité
c'est pas dur c'est de l'intimité il
parlait pas un journaliste n'ont pas su
traduit ça traduit le goût de laval
voient la tuque griveaux a alors ça
évidemment ravi quand même une mentalité
et puis vous avez parlé lutte des
classes mais je crois qu'elle lutte des
classes elle est vraiment recette
noblesse d'état qui on l'a vu sur les
maternités qui enfin quelqu'un qui
connaît mon méprisante vis-à-vis d'eux
je dirais pas seulement de la des
français de la ruralité mais de tous les
français c'est à dire qu on est dans une
ils sont dans leur tour d'ivoire et une
méprise
voilà nous vos chroniques louis move
c'est parce que nous on n'est pas dans
une tour d'ivoire et et je pense que ici
autour du plateau personne ne pense que
on n'a plus droit à une certaine
intimité et que tout ce qui est dit
doivent être rendues aux mines une fois
qu'on à 19 heures sauf qu'une fois qu'on
a dit ça une fois qu'on a dit qu'en
effet la parole après une fois qu'elle
devient public ça devient beaucoup plus
compliqué à gérer
une fois que c'est dit il est quand même
compliqué de ne pas inscrire les propos
qu'il a tenus dans quelque chose de plus
large que l'on voit depuis un certain
nombre d'années au sein même dans des
bus sur le gouvernement et des proches
par exemple de macron mai mais il y en a
d'autres et on pourrait citer un certain
nombre de médias etc
certaines sphères qui ont une certaine
forme de mépris c'est soit conscient ou
inconscient à l'égard de ceux qui ne
ressemblent pas et qui n'auraient pas la
bonne parole dans la partie conscience
j'ai mûri boulot c'est ça je crains
qu'il n'ait pas pris conscience de la
portée de ce qu'il raconte c'est un peu
l'ayatollah du progrès du progressisme
divine monde voilà et je suis persuadé
qu'il a vraiment pas pris conscience de
la portée ces propos et du mépris qui
d'être car dans cette déclaration là
mais ça n'a rien d'un porte-parole denis
loré mangue
il aurait pu démentir ce qui l'a pas
fait ce qui est tout à son honneur parce
que ça veut dire qu'il assume ses propos
il aura pu aussi dire bah j'ai fait une
connerie java pas dû dire ça parce que
ce qu'il a choisi de ne pas faire sur le
fond du sujet et cette histoire de deux
diesel puisque les taxes ont augmenté
les taxes qui s'ajoute à l'augmentation
des prix du carburant duo au marché et
au cours du pétrole
c'est de toute évidence un axe de
faiblesse aujourd'hui pour le
gouvernement
écoutez ce que disait boris vallot il
est député socialiste des landes et il
était sur rtl hier matin la réalité
c'est que dans le quinquennat
les taxes sur le carburant sur le fuel
vont augmenter de 55 milliards d'euros
et 10 à 20 milliards au maximum seront
consacrés la transition énergétique
le reste c'est du matraquage fiscal
et tous eu toutes ces dépenses elle pèse
d'abord sur le budget des ménages les
plus modestes
en fait c'est il ya un peu un effet
double lame voulais dire à van et los
les propos de benjamin griveaux ont
autant d'échos parce que derrière cette
réalité là qui effectivement les les
classes populaires qui peuvent pas
prendre les transports en commun déguste
entre guillemets oui mais on avait déjà
eu ce débat et c'est même argument
lorsque gpa
mis à la casse quantité de voitures
parce qu'elle était trop plus long terme
10 mai où on n'est pas content il ya des
gens qui peuvent pas changer de voiture
je suis d'accord avec tout ça avec ses
avec ses arguments comme quoi il y est
il est nécessaire dans ces politiques là
d'accompagner des personnes qui sont
économiquement les plus faibles pour
pour les pour les faire suivre de
considérer que parce que vous n'avez pas
les moyens par exemple de changer votre
voiture est de vendre votre diesel pour
acheter une voiture à essence qui
consommerait beaucoup moins et que du
coup ça vaut christ de considérer que
pour autant vous en foutez de
l'environnement ça c'est une facilité
que je trouve absolument déplorable et
d'en profiter pour faire une opposition
entre des élites progressistes dans leur
tour d'ivoire et des gens plus simple
qui qui sont déconnectés et qu'on finit
par mettre en colère c'est pas vrai on
peut faire partie de la classe moyenne
et vivre dans les régions de france et
être directement concernés et
sensibiliser et prêts à faire des
efforts pour l'écologie donc que de
renvoyer de faire un clivage là dessus
je trouve ça profondément malhonnête et
injuste pour encore une fois des gens
qui n'habitent pas à paris qui ne sont
pas des bobos qui vont pas chez
naturalia et qui roulent pas en
trottinette et qui pour autant vivent
plus au contact de la nature que nous
qui voit les dégâts qu'ont fait subir à
cette nature depuis des années et qui
sont prêts eux aussi à se mobiliser
qu'il y ait des politiques
d'accompagnement c'est indispensable
mais de vouloir ramener ça à des
postures idéologiques je trouve ça a
bien je pourrais faire on peut faire un
comparatif avec la loi qui enfin le
hidalgo qu'il avait décidé d'interdire
l'accès à de paris dans des voitures qui
sont trop hauts de seine pour moi ça
fait partie de toutes ces mesures anti
pauvres en fait c'est à dire que
comprend même pas un critère écologique
là on prend un critère de l'ancienneté
de la voiture qui est pas forcément lié
à son cash devant ciani et donc ancien
pollue plus parce qu'il ya moins de
repos des chars après ancien de cette
voiture de collection
non mais les gens qui viennent de
banlieue qui peuvent qu'y en a qui n'ont
pas d'accès en rer et qui voit on
travaille à paris et qu'on leur empêche
de prendre leur voiture ça c'est une
politique anti pauvres maintenant
l'enjeu à mon avis c'est vraiment de
lester l'innovation sous-entendait que
les gens qui n'ont pas beaucoup de
revenus se [ __ ] des l'écologie et je
suis content de 800g bison pas forcément
le choix ils n'ont pas forcément le
choix est aujourd'hui le matraquage
fiscal il est réelle c'est à dire qu'on
est le jour de libération fiscale en
france et le 27 juillet c'est le plus
élevé de tous les achats nets consacre
aujourd'hui il ya des efforts énormes
qui ont été faits grâce à l'innovation
les voitures sont beaucoup moins
polluante
parce que on a innové parce que je veux
mais comment qui avait fait ce qui avait
été fait par juppé vous mettez des
primes arguant je pense que déjà si on
libère les revenus des gens on pourra
permettre de leur permettre de consommer
mieux et de consommer des surplus
écologique moi je pense que c'est
surtout l'affrontement au réel de ces
gens effectivement ces français en
général qui devrait en avoir tué matin
je ne dis pas qu'ils sont pas
écologiques du verre à vin biologique
simplement qu'il ya un affrontement au
réel tous les matins ou du moins une
fois par semaine quand on va au prix à
la pompe
ça présente un budget non négligeable
c'est extrêmement important et je crois
que je sais pas comment ça va se passer
on est dans l'est dans les jours à venir
les semaines à venir
on a parlé je crois de blocage le 17
novembre là on touche vraiment à quelque
chose qui tient les gens de tous les
jours tous les jours tous les jours qui
représente un poste de dépense
extrêmement important et là c'est
l'affrontement aurait elle du jour 2 et
du pouvoir d'achat de chaque français
voilà mes appels écologistes problème
chargé en question qu'est ce qui vaut
bien il vaut mieux que les gens en face
des plus ou moins chers comme ça ça
libère des revenus qui pourront et qui
leur permettront d'acheter une voiture
moins polluante à l'avenir ou est ce
qu'il vaut mieux les taxes et les
enfermer dans l'eure avec leurs voitures
polluantes cessa de la question si vous
vous rendez compte que le diesel
saisonniers plus économique vous
racheter un diesel votre site admission
com ag ainsi la tendance est que les
jambes ne pas trop penser au luxe ils
ont une conscience écologique on leur
laisse les revenus là on leur laisse le
plein shwan sur le revenu ils feront les
choix et kiki qui re qui sont
conséquents qui permettront d'avoir une
consommation écologique
bon laissons le faire si la série à
nîmes christian qui nous dit vous croyez
que ça me fait plaisir d'avoir un vieux
diesel
j'ai plutôt honte de temps polluée si je
pouvais avoir une hybride ça ferait
longtemps que je serais passée à une
prius par exemple publicité gratuite
pour une voiture de la maison toyota et
je hais et josé qui nous dit c'est tout
sauf idiot cette remarque par ses propos
grivot est il prêt pour être le candidat
bobos de paris vous savez que benjamin
griveaux est candidat à sa succession
d'anne hidalgo effectivement à ça pour
le coup ce serait assez cohérent ce sont
nos internautes qui sont les meilleurs
dans cette émission les invités mais on
les invite pour les invite grâce à
twitter view mais on est quand même ravi
de vous avoir vous aussi voilà c'est
tout le monde et tout le monde et tout
le monde a la note maximum comme chez
jacques martin on passe à un sujet
européen le parti démocrate-chrétien
d'angela merkel enchaînent les revers
électoraux il y en a encore eu un
dimanche dernier du coup la chancelière
a annoncé qu'elle allait quitter la
présidence de son parti donc la cd ou et
qu'elle ne se représenterait pas en 2021
la prochaine échéance législatives en
tout cas si la coalition va jusque là
alors angela merkel s'était l'allié de
d'emmanuel macron elle est toujours en
poste mais néanmoins affaiblie
on sent bien que c'est difficile le
projet européen du gouvernement français
actuellement pour essayer de le relancer
nathalie l'oiseau la ministre chargé des
affaires européennes a décidé de une
grande consultation citoyenne pardon ça
s'appelle quel est votre europe et elle
en a précisé les contours ce matin au
conseil économique social et
environnemental
un moment nous voyons trop souvent
le populisme quel que soit son bord se
réclamait de la parole citoyenne
nous avons voulu vous avez voulu
redonner la parole directement ou peuple
voilà l'enthousiasmé ministériel fait
plaisir à voir
olivier ravanello c'est vrai au delà des
plaisanteries facile que c'est compliqué
en ce moment pour pour la vision
européenne portée par emmanuel macron
français pas la consultation qui va
changer quelque chose
c'est absurde traquer les votre europe
on peut avoir des milliers de réponses
et tant mieux s'il ya des milliers de
réponses ça veut dire que si on est
capable de générer des milliers de
réponses différentes que chacun ya
réfléchi que se sont impliqués et à une
béa et à une idée à proposer sur ce
projet je je je trouve que là on est on
est simplement dans un petit moment de
panique ou au contraire ce gouvernement
qui se revendique pro européen depuis la
campagne ferez mieux d'afficher
clairement et de marteler un discours
pro européen plutôt que d'essayer de se
réfugier derrière une consultation
citoyenne pour dire moi alors c'est pas
nous qui le pense on sait les français
regardent et on a pris ce qui nous
arrange et dans la consultation ou au
contraire d'en profiter pour faire
machine arrière
il ya un vrai enjeu sur ce que doit être
l'europe
on parlera sans doute de ce qu'on
appelle les populismes et et voilà que
macron se retrouve seul
c'est c'est le moment d'assumer un
magasin qui a répondu en tout cas cette
consultation avant même qu'elle soit
lancée
c'est là en vo qui est encore lui il est
en train de faire une tournée en europe
1 / / pour prendre un peu le pouls de la
situation sur le continent et il était
hier en grèce et sur son compte twitter
il a posté cette petite vidéo
la grèce aujourd'hui c'est la porte
d'entrée de toute l'immigration
irrégulière en europe et donc ce que
j'ai voulu et toute l'équipe des
républicains c'est aller directement sur
le terrain comprendre pourquoi ça marche
pas et tout ce qu'il faut qu'on puisse
changer pour passer de l'europe des
frontières ouvertes celle de macron à
une europe qui protège celle que nous on
défend au moins nicolas v à lui sait
quelle europe il veut oui effectivement
mais bon on ira plus fermé oui n'auront
pu faire mais encore faudra-t-il qui
nous pose qui se veut il semaines par
rapport au traité européen qui a été
signé parce que là aussi sur
l'immigration avec frontières schengen
ya quand même beaucoup de choses à
revoir il ya beaucoup de choses à mettre
en place et voir quelle france il verra
la place de la france et de sa
souveraineté
parce qu'en revenant macron qui parle
depuis quelques semaines déjà de
souveraineté européenne j'aimerais bien
savoir ce que correspond la souveraineté
européenne qu'est ce que c'est la
souveraineté européenne
aujourd'hui donc laurent wauquiez aussi
je pense qu'il y aura il y aura il n'est
pas très claire sur ces questions là
d'ailleurs aux républicains aussi sont
pas très claires puisque il ya plusieurs
courants aujourd'hui qui s'affrontent et
on a du mal à trouver une ligne
directrice forte pour se positionner sur
les européennes de mai 2019 voilà c'est
vrai qu'on se demande si par exemple
alain juppé tiendrai le même discours
que celui qu'on verra dans la bouche de
laurent wauquiez rachel vinasse votre
point de vue on a on voit que le ray
fédéral se brise
du moins se fragilise fortement en ce
moment alors on pourra parler de la
montée des nationalismes dans un certain
nombre de pays on a évoqué en gala
merkel qui est en situation extrêmement
délicate et déjà au sein même de son
pays un outil qui traverse quelques
quelques secousses mais on l'a dit enfin
on se demande quel est le modèle de que
le maquereau propose quel est le modèle
à part nous expliquer que c'est l'union
européenne des progressistes qu'on a
compris qu'il avait les méchants
nationaliste les gentils progressiste ça
il n'y a pas de souci mais concrètement
de quoi de quoi elle se compose de quoi
elle est faite avec qui comment il ya
aucune feuille de route un réel ça reste
encore extrêmement extrêmement floue et
aytré désincarné quelque part laurent
papier votre point de vue sur ce sujet
qu'on va vous demander juste après qu'on
ait pris connaissance de la question
twitter selon vous est-ce la fin du
projet européen porté par emmanuel
macron et vous ne répondez oui et 73% on
répète une fois de plus qu'il s'agit pas
d'un sondage mais de réactions à chaud
d'internautes qui suivent l'émission
ce dont nous les remercions laurent
papilles je crois que les fondements
européens sont attaqués de toutes parts
que ce même même par emmanuel macron
c'est à dire que on avait construit
l'europe comme un espace de libre
échange de 6 de libre circulation
tout ça est aujourd'hui en train d'être
attaquée d'une part par des gens qui
sont conservateurs et nationalistes et
puis d'autre part par ce mot
progressiste qui veut mettre en place d
harmonisation sociale d'harmonisation
fiscale il n'y a pas de vraie vision
à chaque fois on est dans une vision de
l'aggravation du système européen il ya
merkel elle un très piètre un très
piètre
bilan de ces peut-être plus de dix ans à
la tête de l'allemagne
il n'y a pas eu il ya rien eu sur sur le
ils ont ils ont ils ont très mal géré la
crise grecque ils ont laissé cet état
voyou continuer à exister on a en a pas
on a pas on n'a pas réglé ce problème là
la grèce je passe sur que soit le
problème migratoire son premier problème
c'est un problème important mais le
problème premier problème c'est cette
génération sacrifiée et qui est
aujourd'hui suivi des taxes considérable
pour payer les errements de deux
politiciens corrompus et qu'ils aient la
caste du système grec et qu'on n'a pas
du tout dont on doit passer de table
rase et on a maintenu sa et c'était à la
fois merkel et sarkozy
et ça c'est un piètre bilan et les
conséquences aujourd'hui se font elles
se font voir dans l'est dans l'est dans
les votes notamment en italie ou en
hongrie que c'était quelque chose qui
est terrible olivier ravanello est-ce
que emmanuel macron est encore en mesure
de poursuivre ce projet de d'intégration
européenne renforcée qu'il appelait de
ses voeux lors de son arrivée à l'elysée
la politiquement ça va être compliqué
parce qu'il est quand même beaucoup plus
seul ensuite peut-être qu'il faudrait
arrêter de considérer que l'europe est
un programme l'europe est une réalité
institutionnelle et que ce qui est en
train de se passer de mon point de vue
c'est que tous ces mouvements c'est
parti dans différents pays qui sont en
train après avoir critiqué l'europe de
dire qu'ils veulent au contraire faire
changer l'europe de l'intérieur
la seule bonne nouvelle que je vois même
si je partage évidemment pas évidemment
pas évidemment que je ne partage pas du
tout leur valeur
c'est que ils font de la politique et
qu'on va peut-être se mettre enfin à
faire de la politique en europe ce qui
de mon point de vue a tué l'europe
pendant toutes ces années c'est quand
expliquer aux gens que il y avait une
règle rester comme ça et qu elle pas le
choix en fait est que ce n'était pas par
votre vote vous pouvez allez un petit
peu plus à gauche ou un petit peu plus à
droite ça marche comme ça il ya des
règles
ce discours ne tenait pas puisque ces
règles quand il s'agissait de s'en
affranchir et qu on s'appelait
l'allemagne ou la france vont s'en
affranchissait mais quand il s'agissait
comme encore aujourd'hui de l'italie à
ben non on leur dit c'est la règle on
peut pas en sortir
donc ça a créé un sentiment de 2
deux distances des des européens par
rapport à ces institutions qui étaient
illisibles avec des prises de décisions
qui étaient illisibles
si enfin on va pouvoir se mettre à faire
de la politique à se taper sur la gueule
à dire ben non moi je suis pour des
frontières ouvertes non moi je suis pas
d'accord on va enfin faire en sorte que
comme dans n'importe quel état il y ait
des choix politiques et on va proposer
européens d'avoir des choix politiques
et peut-être confiants ils vont
s'intéresser à l'europe parce que il y
aura des alternatives à un retour du
référendum et le nombre d'agressions
dire qu'une fois que vous avez posés çà
vous voir le monde fantoche avec le
genre d'homme élu ce parlement se
restructure d'accord avec justement les
partis qui arrive il va pas du tout être
fantoche mars qui aura des vrais qui
l'âge et des vrais blocages
oui parce que je me permets ya encore eu
un sondage qui est sorti sur le palm je
parlais morin seconde parce qu'on va
rendre barre des 20% des français
aujourd'hui ont une image négative du
parlement 20% des français c'est une
étude du parlement belge négative -
exactement jeunes au parlement européen
hawks extrêmement important et moins
d'un tiers des français connaissent la
date des élections européennes voyez
vous c'est en mai prochain pour ceux qui
l'auraient oublié
laurent pas bien dernier votre avis mais
je me méfie beaucoup de ses projets
politiques 113e au niveau européen je
préfère des petits états qui font des
erreurs qu'un gros et à europe 1 qui
fait une énorme erreur et bien au moins
ça c'est clair on laisse le dernier mot
internet parce que le débat fait rage
frère et toc qui n'est pas très
optimiste qui nous dit l'europe est
foutu trop de parlementaires trop de
temps pour voter une simple loi trop de
lobby heureusement il ya emery qui lui
est plus volontariste et qui nous dit
les citoyens européens veulent reprendre
en main leur destin avec plus de
démocratie directe et plus de
transparence
eh bien vous aurez l'occasion de vous
exprimer ce sera le 25 mai prochain pour
être précis des élections européennes
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre et
d'avoir participé à cette émission point
de vue revient demain j'aurai le plaisir
de vous accueillir à la même heure au
même endroit bonsoir à tous
[Musique]